thank you to brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video get smarter at
maths and physics free solving problems
at brilliant org slash Simon Clark
we have one of those access to lots of
people follow this YouTube channel
because of the vlogs I made during my
PhD in atmospheric physics at the
University of Exeter
unfortunately however I had to graduate
at some point and that necessarily meant
the end of my videos showing what doing
a PhD was like however there are lots of
people out there doing interesting PhD
projects and so in this video series I'm
spending a few days with a new
researcher each episode showing you what
their life is like learning a bit about
them and learning about the topic of
their thesis in this episode I'm at the
European Organization for Nuclear
Research also known as CERN to talk to a
researcher who's just starting out in
her PhD researching and producing
antimatter hello welcome to CERN first
impressions on being here it's very
beautiful there are mountains sort of
you know reading it we were in
Switzerland for goodness sake you could
argue that this is like the global home
of physics it's like the poster child
for all physics research and feels like
any University campus science kind of
area it's a mix of buildings different
ages a bunch of pipe sticking out some
of them all the exciting starts
happening underground or in mines all of
the internal roads are named after
physicist oh so that's fun also it's
quite a big site there's actually an app
you can download to help you navigate
around when I got here yesterday I
immediately got lost I had arrived the
previous day to meet a whole bunch of
PhD students taking part in the early
careers conference entrapped ions this
was an academic conference hosted at
CERN aimed at giving young scientists in
their PhD or their early postdoctoral
work a chance to network and present
their research as were the other
academic conferences this took place via
presenting posters with some incredible
titles and also through giving talks I
was invited to give the final talk at
the conference on effective digital
science communication ok I seem to spot
one
for another I didn't know where I was
outside and I found the building it's a
big I didn't want first to go in the
building
however after navigating the labyrinth
of corridors I was able to find a
lecture theatre and give my talk I think
that went well
with this done I was then on my way to
the antimatter Factory yes that is
literally on the side of the building to
talk to PhD students Yoanna pesckow what
researchers came from all over the world
to attend the conference Yoanna suitcase
by Asha is in the first year of doing
her PhD actually at CERN okay I guess
the first thing is what drew you to this
particular research project like why
this and none of the other stuff that's
going on the CERN because I'm team
others
this may well be true but earlier I
asked Asha why she had ended up in
physics at all and her answer was rather
unique so before we go any further with
her research I want to showcase her
reason for studying physics in the first
place whenever I was teenager I thought
like wow CERN is cool I would like to
work at CERN but I could for a little
knowledge about that and in general like
I don't know if should I talk my story
why I went into physics I think it's
pretty funny but I don't know that
should go in public because essentially
I had such a terrible physics teacher in
my high school that I had to put so much
backward to learn physics that I spent
so much time breathing and I realized
wow it's funny it's not only like a
pendulum and you calculate frequency
it's a lot of funny stuff for very long
time I just believed interesting thing
is chemistry because like how atoms
molecules are built and physics is just
as boring thing like calculating I don't
know the velocity on the slow blah blah
blah blah and then I discovered this
interesting part in chemistry was
actually physics okay so with that bit
of background which incidentally is
completely correct after doing an
internship at CERN Asha started her PhD
in antimatter antimatter is
essentially like mother different except
for accent electrons okay yeah so like
each particle should have corresponding
antiparticle and the difference between
them will be charged so whenever we have
electron with negative charge some mass
etcetera there should be some anti
electron which is called positron that
would happen we expect would have
exactly the same features with this
different that it has opposite charge
that it would have the same amount of
charge just opposite sign so you expect
it to interact with gravity with
electromagnetic force and exactly so we
have standard model that expects that
anti particles will behave the same way
as matter particles but we don't know we
are experimentalist so like even though
there are many models people have
different opinions
but no one check it so far and this is
this is our our work to measure
antimatter system and comparative matter
so we're in the antimatter Factory
behind us I already had a look down
somebody hardware it's kind of lots of
experiments connected together right to
actually make your stuff so there's this
helpful diagram which what we're going
to go through so how do we take our anti
products we use protons
Antti process so we are using protons
from the very first early stage of
acceleration so we have protein
cyclotron like one of first accelerators
later those problems would go to LHC and
will investigate Higgs bosons other
interesting stuff so the person's
equation is it's a smaller acceleration
small accelerator is based on this
campus some of those protons are used
for different experiments for us in
antiproton community also for Nuclear
Research in isold and many other smaller
projects we take those protons it has
high enough energy that whenever we
collided with a target you can see the
target is like it was pointed out so
there is a strong interaction here right
the proton beam is a target
iridium target and this interaction
produces antiprotons semantic products
and dance
antiprotons are recaptured and guided to
our antique proton pack trip we call it
an throttle decelerator
so this is the hole that we are in we
are standing here and we are the only
decelerator at CERN we actually won't go
to slower and slower energies because if
we want trap antiprotons if you want two
measurements we need to have them so
lower so we have accelerator
this is like essentially like
accelerator but it works in other
direction it slows down so we'll have a
cycle of antiproton bound you know
you'll undergo many cooling processes
whenever we talk about energy we also
acetate doing a temperature so whenever
I say cooling it means decreasing energy
this is our physicists jargon so will
cool down the beam and then whenever the
beam is it has low enough energy we can
inject it into experiments which are
located in the center of the ring so the
protons have gone from the proton
synchrotron is a massive
we know ring it's it's it's a big ring
then it's coming everything is a tiny
bit and then you you know you produce
antiprotons they come into a smaller
ring and then cool them down further and
then this ring down here what is this is
the Elena experiment that would be next
deceleration stage so even to go lower
and lower in energy
so whenever beam will undergo the cycle
in AD or we inject it to Elena so make
the be more compact with higher
intensity so this part slows down little
bit but mainly it improves the beam I
mean these are lots of different
experiments they're connected together
how many people are working and doing
research
I don't know exact numbers right because
we have few experiments here's my
experiment alpha there is a trap
experiment we also have edges Asakusa
and there is also life experiment based
it could be hundreds of people that
works on this overall yeah I think maybe
that is not as clear is that experiments
are independent so quite often we work
on the same problem but our approaches
are completely different so free groups
try to investigate gravity but each
approach is different and that's how it
should be you want
results but using different techniques
and this is also of course a little bit
of competition right because if you are
the only person who does this thing who
would motivate you to do it as I shall
already mentioned she is part of the
Alpha experiment which isn't just
studying antiprotons instead she's
looking at antiparticle system called
anti hydrogen so antihydrogen is a
system of positron and antiproton
bounded so it's an is an aunty whole
atom
yeah it's the simplest anti atom and so
then we believe like if the standard
model is correct then this should have
exactly the same properties as hydrogen
hydrogen is the best understood system
so it's really good to investigate it
measure measure things that we can
measure and that's why other field that
we're doing is spectroscopy what the
spectroscopy is it sounds really
enigmatical someone who is a physicist
let's bring it to normal life right we
have a system of two particles like in
our case is antihydrogen with antiproton
and positron and these two particles are
like a couple right usually you have
your daily lives your daily problems and
you have like your ground state right
but at some point something happens like
there is some even some excitation let's
say you know they go for days so then we
have like some external factor that
excites this couple and that thing that
excites an atom is photon we add energy
right so we add photon that causes the
electron or anti-electron to excite so
being in higher energy level and then
this cannot last forever right even if
we went for a holiday or went for a nice
day
still we come back to work normal life
we the excite right so we call back to
our ground state
we lose the energy and this is what we
investigate this is the most depressing
explanation of spectroscopy we
investigate if our energy levels on the
hydrogen the same as in terms of
hydrogen so the thing that we measure is
if the difference in energy between
ground state and excited said is exactly
the same because that's spectrum those
energy levels are different unique for
each atom we can distinguish atom by
energies energy is represented by
spectrum
each color represents a different energy
red is less blue is more yeah so this is
spectroscopy in visible range these are
actually the frequencies of light that
we can see it's actual life but of
course we can go beyond that we can go
to ultraviolet we can go to infrared
spectrum of atoms is wider than only
visible but this is like nice to imagine
to understand that whenever we have
normal visible light because you know
there are a lot of PhDs we know each
other
and
like we meet each other on conferences
we meet each other every day here so
like the community we like this bit of
competition just like farming but still
this is a great small community that's
interesting definitely I think it's
different than at the University because
certain is different right you don't
have classes you don't have like this
really academic feeling that you're just
a student and you have thousands of
professors around there are many
students here and I think this is
different from universities whenever you
go to restaurant here you just see
mostly exactly you cannot escape from
CERN because essentially like it's
possible to not leave Stern at all
because there is hotel here right there
are restaurant so you can eat your
breakfast when you are at work then you
go for lunch you come back to work you
stay until dinner and then you go for
dinner
so either you come back to work or you
can stay for years right so if you like
for if you are for short time at CERN
you will be even living in the hotel so
then it's possible that they just don't
leave CERN at all for some reason this
place here is like kind of I don't know
maybe there's not much entertainment
outside so people will hang around
restaurant here anyway and
if that's tricking you into doing more
work yeah I think I think it works like
that but I think a good point is there's
many there many students the resort
there are there this is I can speak
polish I hope you'll forgive the
indulgence but this being such a lovely
morning it's my final day here and there
are mountains all around and continuing
my tradition of every time I visit
somewhere new I'd like to get my my feet
on the ground I go for a run
I'm going to go and run it's a France
and back the sight is so big that
technically I could do this without ever
actually leaving it but I I'm gonna go
out the gate you know properly I cannot
stress them off I dunno if there's
anywhere else on earth and you can just
say oh yeah keep going straight on
Albert Einstein wrote Jetport you can't
miss the border there you go that's the
border don't think anyone's Manning it
me secreting my passport on my person
was not worth it and now I'm in France
that's easy 9 France is pretty it feels
like I'm running on the stairway to
heaven taking a quick breather that's
top of the hill over the hill
not quite far away
but running but sir now just in front of
me my right side is the shrubbery what
on the last day of the conference the
researchers and I got a seriously cool
opportunity to visit some of the
experiments that make up the Large
Hadron Collider or LHC the huge particle
accelerator that runs underneath Sun and
27 kilometers long is the largest most
powerful machine in the world so we're
about to go underground by about 100
metres take a look at the Large Hadron
Collider where the CMS experiment I
cannot keep big fat grid off my face
we're so far underground here that when
we came down in the lift my ears pop as
the atmospheric pressure is much much
higher down here
exponential functions
I wasn't expecting quite how loud it is
down here and obviously the big
experiment and it's an account a cavern
so you know it's self-contained but it's
bloody loud in here this thing is MN an
immensely complex it's not just one big
block of detectors loads of complex
electronics that go on inside it let
alone the data analysis that happens
afterwards the actual thing itself is
super complicated can you tell I'm not a
fast couple with this little fun fact if
you see people taking selfies with the
beam and having come to CMS they haven't
actually seen the beam pipe they're
taken with this very convincing poster
backdrop
hurting ones which I per my social media
it's bizarrely convincing until you see
the edges being here in the experiment
and we're currently in one of the
counting rooms which is where the recipe
beside if an event that happens if the
detector is interesting or not it kind
of feels like you're in the belly of a
massive mechanical electronic beast you
know almost like Jonah and the belly of
a whale like you know this is you're
just surrounded on all sides by concrete
and metal and electronics and the fuels
yeah kind of alive the scale is just
immense there was
in foreign later in the day we also
visited the LHCb
experiments and we were joined by Asha
who what working at CERN hadn't seen
this experiment before so we're
currently underground at the LHC be
experiment this is an LHC be behind me
this is Delfy which is an old experiment
that's just a base clears like a museum
piece we went to how to look at the LHC
be detector which is looking for Clark
composites which are formed from the
bottom quark which is the second
heaviest quark and another quark and
they're doing that to investigate the
imbalance between matter and antimatter
in the universe there's basically this
CP symmetry violation and so all of this
gear thing of this level of technology
behind is probing the most fundamental
building blocks that we are currently
aware of the tiniest possible thing that
can only be accessed on but its immense
scale so Asha obviously CERN is huge and
you know you you work on a completely
different experiment this is your first
time down
do you still get a kick out of seeing
the size of these experiments it's still
like or inspiring I don't feel it's as
huge as if alright like I've been in
many times underground in different
experiment and it's like I rather focus
on the technical parts like let's say oh
they have really nicely padded cables or
like I really love in Atlas because I
don't know how is it called but
essentially you have cables or some
trade that goes out so whenever you run
an experiment any talk about cables and
this is so cool I would love it that we
need to take out some part of equipment
we can just rolled out that was amazing
I think you've been here too long I
think you're turning into an engineer
six hours later so we just came down
this this is completely unmarked dark
stairway I thought I was going to be
brought down here to be murdered so what
was this useful was this was there a
like a Collider or or an accelerator
that went down here or is this just
service tiles I need to disappoint you
I'm guessing it's only serviced out so
people keep here like you know broom
sweeping equipment essentially like
students who don't finish their theses
on time we just leave my food we love
their bodies I know for a second that we
were gonna have like the secret you know
collider that's underneath CERN that
nobody knows about you're telling me
this is a big broom cupboard it looks
safe you I've got it's like it's like
The Return of the Jedi when they're
flying into the Death Star okay this
displays all around
so what's found that restaurant one I'll
go on then
I do need dinner
oh now you tell me this time yeah we
have one of those XK them I'm the world
oh there's like a little hero yeah so we
should have carried on TURN RIGHT that
Junction
I thought these kind of tunnels only
happen in books I didn't think they
actually exist just a basement what are
you hoping your PhD project is gonna be
sorry I asked the question you should
never ask yeah okay so I am working in
parts of experiment which focus on
improving our hydrogen trapping right so
we won't do it by decreasing temperature
of positrons we can decrease temperature
of positrons by mixing it with something
holder and this Condor thing can be at
home atom of beryllium atoms of
beryllium that have been laser cooled
because we have this feature that
interaction between atoms and laser if
there's done in a proper way they can
decrease temperature of Berlin so this
is work I've been doing for last year
together with my colleagues and other
ideas other ideas is to use those
beryllium atoms for magnetometry so for
us a really really important thing is
what is the magnetic field Network a
really really precise measurement we
need to know it to distinguish effects
of gravity from effects from magnetic
field so
my work will focus on finding the
technique developed schemes how we could
use those volume items we already have
in our apparatus to characterize
magnetic field as an atomic probe I'm
not trying to say this to like put you
down but basically you are in a tiny
tiny way improving so you are improving
with the science that is done here not
just like coming in and doing an
experiment already exists you're
actually pushing like knowledge that's
what a PhD is it's like you know it's a
yes it's really small but it's like
you're pushing knowledge forward and
you're still doing it even at certain
you don't have to be so modest
Asha was a wonderful example of someone
who was extremely capable motivated and
personable and yet while still being
early in her PhD was definitely already
feeling the strain of academia doing a
PhD anywhere isn't easy and doing one in
a nearly closed intense environment like
CERN seemed even more like a bubble I
really hope that this year she's able to
move on with her project and do some
science which is seriously cool but much
as CERN is the global home of physics
and the only place in the world to
produce antimatter like this I don't
envy her position there is a lot of hard
hard work to be done but I know that she
is the right person to do it if he found
the topic of antimatter super
interesting and Mike wouldn't you then
maybe you'd like to research it yourself
one day in which case an essential piece
of your tool kit would be quantum
mechanics after all the existence of
antimatter was only postulated by my boy
Paul Dirac when he found the quantum
equation describing the electron had two
solutions one being the electron and the
other being the positron anybody can get
to grips with quantum mechanics with
brilliance expertly written course on
the subject which will allow you to
learn by doing by solving problems and
taking part in interactive quizzes
brilliant also has courses on other
areas of modern physics such as
relativity and quantum computing but
also chemistry maths and computer
science and is generally a phenomenal
educational resource
has daily problems multi-platform
support the dedicated community and
inbuilt wiki you couldn't ask for
anything more from an educational
resource perfect for people at school
high school and particularly if you're
interested in studying science at
university get smarter under your own
steam with brilliant at the link below
and if you use the promo code Simon
Clarke then you can get 20% off and
support this series thank you for
watching the video and thank you of
course to Asher for being so incredibly
generous with her time for showing me
around CERN and explaining her research
to me and to you guys so thank you to
her I had a fantastic time at CERN it
was honestly a dream come true to visit
to see the LHC and to even give a talk
so I must also say thank you to dr.
April Cridland who organized the
conference and invited me to speak and
to the University of Swansea who covered
my travel if you enjoy this series and
would like to see more videos like this
one and pop the video alike and let me
know in the comments what you thought
what you liked and what you didn't like
about this video and if you are a PhD
student with an interesting story to
tell in a video like this one then let
me know all the contacts information is
available on my website thank you again
for watching and I will see you in the
next one now wash your hands